[Music]
what is this this automation is the key
to bridge the gap between user
expectation is via develop a supposed to
fall what iBM is anyone is aware of a
peon continious mentioned that it is a
rapper on CD home actually execution
theorem goes through it is to automate
mobile apps so you know that the
selenium cannot automate mobile apps and
the apps can be native app it can be web
app which can be hybrid app so there are
three type of apps in the market and you
know as you know that the app demanding
of mobile apps is becoming very it's in
demand it's in trend everyone has lots
of apps in the mobile and of course this
thing is more required now it is kind of
mandatory stuff if you are launching any
app in the market so for that of course
selenium cannot do that can automate
your apps so for the appian comes happy
m is also an open switch but how it
actually works did they develop their
own you know what they did you Shalini
put this end that let's use selenium
selenium will be interacting
with happier selenium skill will be
interacting with the appium and appium
will be interacting with UI Automator
and apple whether I need to go fishing
so it will interact with both of these
tools one tool is provided by Google and
one tool is provided by Apple what
happens is you know when google has
launched their place to and when FNS
launched their IT so wherever whatever
their faces are here is what is so of
course they are putting lots of apps on
their Facebook first without biggie your
apps whatever you develop the is it
whether your app is eligible to be
leased or who publish a lot so in that
case they have come up with their own
use in the market and they have their
tool actually okay like here what I have
mentioned but what RPM done appium you
write your strips in selenium selenium
interacts with the rpm and appium
converts your scripts into that
particular form whatever the language
that fools understand they convert them
and that's how this uses hammer so
actually this tool is doing the planet
nothing it is you know working as an
aggregator between these two rules okay
and that's how I can become aware this
is versatile a combined devices are
increasing exponential potentially
testing mobile apps can be very complex
and expensive apps nation support varies
over existence and they're different
versions to improve time to market and
quality of an app by let's test
automation is necessity there are a lot
of open source tools for both Android
and iOS for native web hybrid
application and that are happy in
calabash monkey talk with you
hope I talked about robotium on
promoting mo calabash so in a p.m. the
late advantage is it can accept multiple
languages but ganas calabash does not
accept it cannot accept that different
languages so in selenium as you know
that we it can it accept six languages
six programming languages in the same
way you can use those programming
languages when using a few images but in
calabash you cannot move out this is a
reason I would say you're happy 'm is
somewhere is ahead compared to other
news let's move on in the next time
Photos app iam cross-platform solutions
where you write this for multiple
platform so you can write this for
Android Windows and iOS this one
dependents your mobile device ways
it supports quadruple languages it
allows the execution of natural devices
and simulators closely for a paean this
what you release any language any
framework standard a there and open
source so you can see that this is what
I have mentioned to you as well a PM
uses vendor provided automation
framework
this requires local violation of the
application this means you are testing
exactly the same application without any
changes for details confirmation who are
so what happens is rpm interacts with
the UI Automator by Google
it interacts with the XE test by Apple
it interacts with the window app driver
from Microsoft and that's how it can
automate all three platforms in one go
happy amuses linear driver API is for
all the brainbots appium web driver
wasn't client-server protocol that is
Jason wire protocol Potomac eg one can
use any this you write your test cases
what client libraries are available one
can use any unit SC framework so if you
want Leslie GJ unit or anything like
that you can go ahead and use it
rpm extensive apply one and provides
additional a page a strictly for my desk
automation so of course that's valid the
you know step here that's valid point
but when you use a few many use app in
life ready it gives you some added
classes added methods which is special
to the mobile automation that is swipe
because in mobiles you do swiping tap
because in mobile to do tapping there
are many things which are specific to
the mobile apps which is being provided
by a pin light grading selenium the
primer is widely adopted in the market
for desk automation and this reduces
learning curve for testers because you
know selenium webdriver now you can
easily switch to RPM because there is
not much with what you need to learn the
driver is also WC standard RPM is an
open source framework which is the best
part there is a large community
contributing to its enhancements
absolutely so even if you face any
issues you will get an answer easily
from anyone from the community you know
there is a very big community of this
appian there is a good support from
vendors as well Apple Microsoft and
Google of course you know they will
always keep their automation who's
up-to-date and set somewhere else your
itself
because Google has google launches their
new feeding system they will need sure
that they are tool which is used for the
automation or for the testing purpose it
works perfectly fine with a new
operating system so you know the
dependency that as soon as like here in
selenium will always after sees we will
always have to make sure that our
selenium libraries are up-to-date with
the Firefox version you know with the
checker drivers and all those stuffs not
here
everything is on Google if they are
launched in your browser they should
have their automation views updated so
there is a good support for measures how
the appium box like I mentioned here so
appium access server that implements the
drivers RPM is a server here it is
written in known GS density scripts were
are executed by sending HTTP request
wave app in server using json wire
protocol so here somewhere or the other
they are using selenium grid somewhere
or the other
they are using traces of selenium grid
because what will happen or if I had not
say it as lynnium drain and if you have
heart of selenium RC remote control this
is how what the philosophy they are
following action because your script
sends the commands you have your server
which converts that command which is
acceptable by the home devices and this
is what your remote control server used
to do hardly er you know but results are
sent back to client whose execution so
what is you are not a matter this is
provided by Google and which is the tool
being used by RPM it is you see flame of
wendie's across our function you are
testing for android apps
it is our library containing a set of
lightweight AP is it helped to build
avoid s hand to interact with elements
in user apps and system apps
he means if you if you know if you don't
move let me tell you there are two type
of apps one is using a very system apps
system apps are those apps when you buy
a new
the existing apps which is pre-installed
the despondence system apps which you
cannot unstop I would say in that time
and user apps are those apps which you
download explicitly and which you can
unser
who's on call last user user that there
is a one of the best ones producing
Android app it is bundled with Android
SDK
it is good framework to write black
boxes that this would does not interfere
with the application implementations
it supports Android version 4.3 and mo
so currently we have hero Android eight
so of course below this I don't think so
anyone needed and then it says it
provides a viewer going automate appear
to inspect element'
locators it provides a set of API sruti
state of application and perform actions
on apps on a device who also provides a
set of API is that support cross a few
itis Android SDK whenever you want to
walk with Android apps you'll be needing
Android SDK and this is what you
download from the Google site it helps
you this so there you get UI Automator
viewer okay so let me show you so when
you install Android SDK actually on this
you know when you download SDK there are
schools that is called g1 Automator
viewer when you click on it this is the
SDK what you get from Google itself
correct
it is useful development of apps and it
will actually use other testing in the
apps now as well if your democracy is
content or if you have created any
simulator then you will click on this
link and it will detect your mobile apps
free or mobile on the screen it will
detect your screen and will show you all
these steps right all in the screenshot
right here and on the right inside it
will show you some zero or hierarchy of
code velocity like this so
here is their app this green chalk and
here you will get all D are you know in
a in a child parent-child relationship
you will find your notes and on the
bottom whenever you move your cursor on
any of these elements it will show you
all the radios on that element that the
ID of that element is this the class of
that element is says the package of the
element is this okay the index is one so
if you tell you each and everything on
that particular you are launched all the
UI Automator viewer
I am only launched today so in that it
is saying that go to the Android SDK
tools bin directory and open that and in
that you will find here Lake device
screen shot which is this this one
device is screen shot when you click on
it it will actually take from the screen
shot of your half are of your device
whatever the home page is and then it
which means the properties of the
element wherever you move your cursor
like the entire box you move your cursor
on any element until show you the
properties it shows you the code of that
particular element in the scenery it
will show you the properties of that
particular element so here they are just
showing you as an example that how it
moves up you can see that on the left
hand side when they move their cursor on
this it will show you all the details on
the section right on the right side now
they are also talking about the desired
capillaries so first of all to be
precise it is important that you have
him just keep that in mind that what it
does because when you talk about a p.m.
you will need to download
and right SDK with that you will get
Android studio where you can write your
code in this you will need to learn the
Tao you can
eight simulators with this specific
configuration
then you will see a p.m. server you will
download the app observer and easy
settings in the server then you will
pick see android APK file and you will
see that how you can get the details of
that APK file of the application then
these UI Automator viewer so that you
can locate elements and then you will
start writing yourself these other
things move you can do before you move
on to this desire capability which I am
just going to show you this is just to
give you an overview I would say okay
that's why this is being covered here
does that cover it is a way of
specifying the appium server
capabilities you need in the target
environment since appium caters to
Android iOS and Windows they are a
different set of capabilities for each
so just now in selenium grid we have
seen that what we have seen in selenium
grid that you have to set the platform
you have to say II browse the name
browser version etc in the same way when
you will bring in work on Android these
are the settings what you need to do so
package activity if I definitely hope
these now you might not be able to
understand but so package in Java is
having different different classes in
the same way in Android we have a
package where you are having different
different screens when having different
free screen and each screen is called as
app activity so this is wait activity
they package this is device traded time
out and buy coverage these are the basic
activities they have mentioned that
works reading in order to set up not in
fact but nevertheless you will you know
when you will be able to set up all
those things we will easily be
understand you will easily understand
all these work this real action so this
way I'm not going inside this desire
bridges because without if you maintain
it there is no use of doing te changes
giving it a name and if I call out the
descriptions
but yes if you have anything specific to
ask not know how in grade words how we
need to stall from which website do we
need install is there any option with
Eclipse etc then of course we can take
that right now hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos Dinard up and get
certified click here